الاثناء هدمت جرافات الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منازل المواطن بلنزل المواطن
المقدسي محمد راتب مطر في بلده جبل المكبر
جنوبي مدينه القدس وسرع وزير الامن القومي
كثير بتهزئه رئيس البلديه الاسرائيليه في
القدس المحتله والشرطه على سرعه تحرك
وشروع في هذه المنازل للفلسطينيين في
المدينه
مصادر الاحتلال ان هذه بدايه مجموعه من
البيوت الفلسطينيه في احياء اخرى في
المدينه التي تعتبر غير قانونيه بذريعه
انها غير مرخصه من قبل الاحتلال
بعد الان من جبل المكبر في القدس مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري لنرسد معها اخر
السجدات المتعلقه بسياسه العقاب الجماعي
الجماعي المتمثله بهدم المنازل
فقط الى انه وردنا قبل قليل عن تطبيق منزل
لاحد المواطنين الفلسطينيين في ضاحيه بيت
حنينه شمال القدس المحتل هناك تواجد كبير
لقوات الاحتلال لمنزل عائله شنتير ولكن
ااه يبدو بانه تمهيدا لهدمه ولكن ما زلنا
في متابعه هذا الموضوع من جهه اخرى
تواجدنا قبل قليل في المنطقه التي في
منطقه قريبه جدا من هنا التي تم فيها هدم
منشات تجاريه وكراج للسيارات في جبل
المكبر في القدس المحتله صباح هذا اليوم
بعد ان اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال وجرافات
تابعه لبلديه الاحتلال البلده وبدات بهدم
هذه المنشاه هذا بالاضافه الى هذا اخر
ايضا لسور الاستنادي لعده منازل في بلده
سلوان المحاديه للمسجد الاقصى همم مبارك
لكن هذا هو المنزل او ثلاثه منازل عمليا
تم هدمها يوم امس لعائله مطر في جبل ال-
المكبر ايضا بدريعه البناء دون ترخيص يوم
امس تم هدم هذه المنازل
وشردت ثلاث عائلات من بيت مطر في هذه
المنطقه همم منطقه السواحري همم في جبل
المكبر وهذه السياسه متبعه منذ عده سنوات
وليست جديده لكن همم وزير الامن القومي
كبيره الذي يحاول تصوير بان ذلك
انجازا كما يصفه لحكمته لولايته كوزيلا
للامن القومي وبان ذلك يتم تنفيذا لاوامره
كما نشر همم نشر في بيان صادر عن مكتبه
صباح هذا اليوم تنفيذا لاوامر اعطاها
للشرطه الاسرائيليه بان تقوم بهدم منازل
اا بنيت دون تراخيص في تحديدا في القدس
المحتله علما ان سلطات الاحتلال لا تمنح
الفلسطينيين اي تراخيص بناء في هذه
الاحياء والبلدات الفلسطينيه في الشطر
الشرقي من مدينه القدس تراخيص البناء لا
تتجاوز واحد بالمئه من التصاريح التي
يطلبها سكان هذه المناطق ويقومون بخوض
معارك قضائيه لكن غالبا ما يتماها قرار
المحاكم مع قرار الاحتلال بهدم هذه
المنازل الان سيكون هناك تسريع في عمليه
الهدم بحيث يتم تجاوز هذا الهامش الضيق
الفلسطينيين بان
يستانفوا المحاكم من جهه اخرى قبل قليل
تواصل معنا ايضا احد المواطنين في حي قريب
من هنا وقال بانه شرع باخلاء منزله بعد ان
تلقى اتصالا من مخابر المخابرات همم
مخابرات الاحتلال في مدينه القدس اما ان
يهدم منزله حتى صباح يوم غ منزليها عمليا
منز له منزل لابنه المتزوج او تقوم بلديه
الاحتلال بهدم المنزل صباح الغدو وهو من
يقوم بدفع تكاليف الهدم كما هو متبع في
قانون سلطات الاحتلال الازرار
المكبر في القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري شكرا جزيلا لك